Starbucks is giving its business in
China a huge jolt of Seattle coffee Jon
recently revealed plans to build nearly
3,000 new stores in mainland China over
the next five years that almost doubles
the number of stores there now
round-the-world people consume about a
hundred and fifty-five million bags of
coffee a year that's more than 10
million tons Ben Tracy went to Shanghai
to show us why China is just catching on
to what we call the caffeine crazed it's
no secret there's a whole lot of tea in
China it's tea fields are legendary
providing the leaves for the hundreds of
cups of tea the average person here
drinks every year but now coffee is the
buzz of Beijing this woman says I prefer
coffee coffee tastes like happiness it
is increasingly becoming the caffeine
fix of choice for the middle Kingdom's
rapidly growing middle class coffee
consumption in China has nearly tripled
in the past four years with coffee
imports growing 16 percent a year
compared to about 2% in the United
States you have you know a very young
population that has been exposed to
Western influences Dave sieminski owns
Sumerian coffee in Shanghai he first
came to China to work for Apple but saw
a coffee craze was coming as the Chinese
got wealthier why weren't they just
drinking fancier tea why a big switch to
coffee it's perceived as having a level
of status when you're adopting Western
products so that's why you know
companies like Chanel and her meds and
Starbucks do well here Starbucks just
opened its largest store in the world
right in the heart of Shanghai where
lines sometimes stretch down the street
the company is opening a new store in
China every 15 hours and it now has
plenty of competition here in Shanghai
there are now more than 6500 coffee
shops and to say there's one on every
corner would be a gross understatement
on this corner there's
there's two and there's three Costa
Coffee is opening hundreds of new stores
here thanks to China's Millennials who
are embracing coffeehouse culture to be
seen in a coffee shop with which you
identify yourself see this is a way for
them to express themselves to say who
they are the products they consume the
food they buy the coffee they drink and
there's still a lot of room for the
being business here to grow the average
person in mainland China consumes just 3
cups of coffee per year
compare that at 250 cups per person in
the United Kingdom and 363 cups in the
US but that demand coupled with the
impact of climate change in the world's
coffee supply could lead to a caffeine
crash fewer beans and higher prices for
consumers in the next 30 years China
could be importing 2 to 3 million tons
of coffee and currently the global
supply of coffee is 6.9 million tons if
coffee really does take off here is
there enough supply no thankfully
there's still all that tea in China for
CBS this morning then Tracy Shanghai
they like their coffee in China I like
when you said is that enough no I don't
where to go after that no need a lot of
coffee if you're opening stores every 15
hours really do cheers Cheers
Starbucks Cheers